[Music]
look at this place and eMoney the sun is
shining everybody's out there having fun
makes you want to get out there and join
them doesn't it well I'll see
[Music]
you now do not forget you are the help
they are the guest your spritzer has
arrived finally you got to get out of
your shell buddy come on Armen I'm not
like these other crabs all right I don't
throw my claws in the
air I don't wave them like I just don't
care what's up W wakey this is for your
own good army
[Music]
but ask you to dance what you got move
girl what did you say to me no no no no
no no that wasn't me that was uh him him
who me me me oh he's so
cute hey look
out aren where are you H oh man how far
are we from the ocean and in crab legs I
don't know maybe a million this may be
the furthest away from my mother I've
ever been woo it feels amazing girl have
you lost your
mind oh this my
dam How You Like Me
Now how you doing you know lost and
afraid for my life other than that can't
complain come on open your eyes I liked
it better when they shut what are you
doing kid oh
[Applause]
for it is good to see you out of the
house
AR what do you think they'll think of us
oh
snap are you finished yet C crib cuz
you're standing and not drinking
water